what we
K good afternoon welcome along
counselors staff and those joining us on
the live stream for this meeting of the
community well-being committee uh I have
apologies from councelor kit May Clark
somebody like to
move Leslie and Evelyn put that all in
favor against carried brings us through
there being no are there any
declarations that anybody has to make
I'm aware of one from partney but still
signified at the time and also from me
for the same just just note that at the
time and no need to withdraw from the
table just don't participate in the
discussion uh that brings us good
afternoon manger uh
to to the minutes of the city center
Heritage subcommittee move those counc
so seconded councel Arnold any matters
are
rising if not put that all in favor I
against carried minutes of the last
meeting of the community well-being
committee councelor Campbell
move seconded Grant any matters
Rising I'll put that then all in favor I
against
carried and we copies of the minutes
from the January meetings of the
district licensing committee which I'm
happy to move or received see by
councelor SOA put that all in favor
against carried thank you which brings
us to the proposal to revoke Reserve
status I will obey Road reserves just
noting that I have a sorry uh so you
here just had a Tex Caroline's running
slightly late but she'll be here soon so
right should we slop here to the next
item then please if you could right I'm
sensing raspberry
lington um she not involved the next
matter as well Mr not so much it's more
a reanon
one so it's the unmanned aial vehicle
policy
review um ran and from a a process
status largely this policy is about
implementing regulations that exist
outside of council is
it that's correct um Kota counselors um
Darren is just going to do just a BRI
overview yes the other one just for
clarity um is going to do a brief
overview of the process and then happy
to take questions thanks Darren all
yours thank you Mr CH can you want to
pull that microphone around
please thank
you uh this report brings to you the
draft on Mandy real vehicle policy uh
with recommendations from officers and
stakeholders after early engagement the
policy mainly deals with the use the
operation of uavs of council own or
operated land or reserve and not a
private or residential land uh formal
consultation is not recommended as the
changes proposed in the policy are
identified as of low significance U
early engagement was conducted and 45
participants were invited to give
feedback on the draft policy this
included uh inag Airport New Zealand
poers environment Southland to incorpor
ated and applicants that came to council
to apply for the UAV consern in the past
years uh the version of the policy that
is presented today has incorporated all
the feedback received following early
engagement the main recommendations
proposed are the addition of definitions
provided in uh provided in
recommendation 3C of the report uh to
update the scope of the policy to
provide special privileges to New
Zealand uh Pol and New Zealand Emergency
Management agencies to use uav's over
Council owned or operated land or
Reserve to remove Elizabeth Park Agy
Park and mury Park from schedule one of
the policy and add Kennington
recreational Reserve uh to add more
weight to privacy matters to give
effective objective three of the
proposed policy uh to restructure the no
fly zone of the current policy to go uh
to make it more user friendly and
informative uh to specify the need uh
for specific approvals if the uh the UAV
intends to Closs over to a Waterway foot
path or Road and to specify the need for
for areas provided in schedule one to be
booked uh this is done in practice but
not mentioned within the current
policy thanks Darren I guess it's one of
those things as an overview where it's
it's difficult in that you can buy
drones
from many hardware stores and people
don't realize that they come with uh
rules and
responsibilities and um I mean I don't
own any form of projectile Weaponry but
if one was flying over my house for an
extended period of time I'd bust out the
softball
pitch um there are um um Council
reserves which is what this this deals
with and there's been extensive
consultation with those who have a
specific but I think opening it up wider
than that isn't really helpful you
essentially have a whole lot of people
who buy a drone and go I want to flight
where I want to flight um I mean I could
buy a fast car and go I want to drive it
at 200ks but the police will have a
different view because those are the
regulations and that's essentially what
we're giving effect to there's a series
of recommendations in the agenda I'll
open it for discussion before I ask
remover
Tom so just a question one of the things
that struck me is said Ed this was the
question why we need one at all when
there already is a national policy so
what is it special about Council on land
that we need a separate
one uh so under the CAA uh a permission
is required to operate a drone over a
land so in this case a council land so
this is essentially a guideline or like
uh how what are the things that we need
to be aware of when you are planning to
operate our UAV over
Cel does that answer your question
Tom not exactly um I mean I'll try to
rephrase it I'll just try to understand
that I mean obviously There Are Rules
applies to the whole of the city our
land Council land represents a fraction
of the whole of the city the remaining
majority of the city are governed by
other laws so my question was why can't
those laws simply be used for Council
line too rather than have a special
policy R would you like a b um it's
certainly not a legally required policy
nevertheless it is common practice
amongst most councils to have a clear
set policy because many people do wish
to use Council land for flying drones
for various reasons
um most private householders they're not
going to write a policy about how they
would respond to somebody flying over
their private land but
they would just deal with it with how
they want to but we will this enables us
to be transparent about when when we
will say just go ahead just fly a drone
it's fine or when actually you need to
get permission for a particular piece of
land or when we need to make clear to
people who might not be aware that for
example it's not us it's environment
South and where there's a Waterway um
and just being really clear that we're
supporting the um airport in terms of
communication around the pieces of land
that are actually under the flight path
and I guess further to that Council
adopting a policy is another way of
Shining Light on the fact that there are
some regulations that people need to be
aware of Alex um so I'm just trying to
find it in the report where I read where
um it said that we'd gone out to a
number of people who were recent users
of drones um
to offer them to read the policy and you
know help pick it to pieces and see you
know find some discrepancies and such
but um how did you get the list of
recent users was that the users that had
applied to council to ask us if we could
well ask for permission to apply the
council land or was it from the airport
when people put in petition to be able
to fly around the airspace like where
where was that user pool generated from
uh it's the uh people who came to uh
came to council to apply for the council
you
can how would we go about capturing
those that aren't aware that these
guidelines exist we can't simply by this
process and by shining a light on it I
mean if somebody goes in and makes a
purchase from say Harvey Norman there's
no registration process that to go
through
no it's just something that UAV users
need to be aware of and it's not on the
packaging anywhere it's in the software
um attached to the more
um popular
and high spe drones y it's like terms
and
conditions people take the box no no no
sorry you you can't you literally can't
fly without permission from the airport
they literally will not get off the
ground um unless you've got permission
to be able to fly in that particular
aace if you're within a particular
radius so the answer was we didn't get
any of those usernames from the earport
those are people who come through
Council um absolutely we got as Darren
says we we consulted with the list of
everybody that's got um a um what had
applied to us but we also did engage
with the airport and have had feedback
from them um and so they're confident
that the policy as it's described is um
what would meet the needs of people who
were approaching them for
information um and then obviously just
as with any policy there's a
communication Factor as well um so the
guidelines have been refreshed and we'll
certainly work with the comm's team on
making sure people are aware Co Ren
cook yes thank you Mr ch um I guess my
question has partly been answered by
your comment as The Shining the light on
the on the issue because I was
interested in the exclusion Zone and
Bluff and it's only because I know
somebody who has flown a drone
over alai has excellent footage but I
would imagine is within the exclusion
zone for the helipad and I so to the
point that Council crackett made I'm not
sure whether all the equipment is
actually frozen and can't fly because
otherwise I wouldn't have thought that
particular drone would have been able to
go where it went however I do think that
as well as policy that pertains to our
lands and highlighting the issues with
other interested
parties we have an obligation to our
citizens to make sure that where where
possible they are complying with
legislation so everything that we do
that highlights to them that there may
be a permission that they need to have
that there may be other effective
parties that they have not considered um
we're doing we're doing our community a
service by by highlighting those issues
not just protecting our interests or uh
you know the safety concerns
of whoever um respecting people's
personal privacy and wishing that I
could see your softball I'm an action um
I do think I I have heard other people
say um and I have seen it um at the um
end of trenway road where there has been
considerable drone activity at times
that people have commented on how
annoying it is can't say it's affected
me but if we are drawing our citizens
attention to the fact that it isn't just
open slather just because you can afford
to buy one that there are courtesies and
regulations that you have to follow
we're doing the whole community of
service so I thank you for your work um
I must admit that it was a bit more
information than I thought I was going
to see councilor so thanks Mr chair it's
a comprehensive and almost International
and scoped policy I have to say um and I
I actually think one of the values of it
from the point of view of Public
Communication is that the public are
hearing we've got the policy and I
thought it was particularly of Interest
probably to a lot of people um that
we've taken Elizabeth Park and AR Park
out of schedule one and put Kennington
in that alone I think is worth the
advertisement in the chat around the
table
because it's actually telling people
that Elizabeth Park and AR Park do not
need the um the application under
schedule one um which I think is a
useful piece of information for members
of the public to know about of itself
you're somewhere to go yeah
congratulations it's a it's a
comprehensive policy thank you thank you
thank you Steve was it just you so that
was a pin um but I think to be fair just
to note the importance of a pretty
robust communication strategy for the
public which Ran's already mentioned um
because I was reading this and thinking
about all the hobby um operators wedding
operators real estate agents but I look
I don't know I see lots of Drone footage
and I'm not always sure that'd be
following this policy so obviously
drawing the comms is
key noted the same thing and I also not
a lot of Drone footage and some of those
from actually within the the no fly zone
but there are circumstan is where
approved users with consent from the
control tower alert them to when they're
going to fly and the control tower say
no flights you're good to go you've got
this window so not impossible but again
it's just about good open communication
I'm quite sure that none of those
commercials have happened outside of
that knowing the operators they won't
actually that's not a fous comment no
um somebody like to move the three
recommendations which includes a through
to L on three R cook and Trish
any further questions or
comments not to put the motion then
thank you all in favor against carried
councilors we'll go back to tab seven
and do a swap at the
table uh and again noting that uh Pia
and Evelyn will step aside from uh any
of the discussion around
that thank you you have the uh have the
floor car yeah good afternoon um so what
we've got is the the review of The
Proposal to revoke Reserve status at Al
obay Road reserves for the purpose of
disposal with two fee simple land
Parcels background being there's two uh
sorry there's four Parcels of land along
aay road which are owned and managed by
Council undeveloped land Parcels
classified as Recreation reserve and
local purpose reserve and they're
identified in the Parks strategy in 2013
subsequently in the long-term plan in
2015 as is being Surplus to requirements
we've undertaken the public
consultation to revoke Reserve status um
as was endorsed by the Community wellbe
Committee on the 8th of August
2023 um obviously any future use land
use in this area all need to comply with
the underlying operative District plan
requirements we followed a criteria that
was again endorsed in the community
wellbeing committee on the 8th of August
2023 um and they were assigned as
non-strategic land low value meaning
that not forecast is being required for
growth and development for the community
we've undertaken a review of community
views and the public notification was um
undertaken as per the reserves act
1977 The Proposal was publicly notified
in accordance with that act um in the
Southland times twice and information
was made available on let's talk we
received seven submissions for and
support two against and one was neutral
so the purpose for today is for the
committee to please consider the report
and the submissions we received um on
the proposal to revoke the reserve
status on those Parcels of land all of
which are currently undeveloped um with
the report um demonstrating the
preferred option is to proceed uh with
requesting the commissioner that is the
Department of Conservation to revoke the
reserve status for the purpose of
sale thank you councils there are 13
recommendations the first seven deal
with the the process that we've gone
through uh um receiving the submissions
and the consideration and the last six
recommendations from this committee
which have to be approved by council is
somebody prepared to move them councilor
SOA
seconded by me open for discussion
Council poer um look mine's my first
question and I just want to stick to
this first one is about the
recommendations you've just moved uh can
I have someone please explain number six
to
me
I had a read of it and it
it I'm I'm just struggling to understand
it so I'm either having a bad day or can
someone please explain it to me probably
should have
uh pointed out that we were looking for
the allowed accepted options councilor
soapa uh and with that
Amendment does that offer you some
clarity no
okay so that
about um the
committee understanding and recognizing
where council's position is in the
process that's my reading of it so how
do we right how do we get that position
of council well everything that's gone
through there that started back in
August of last year so the first seven I
think recommendations about our process
through the previous meeting uh the
submission process the hearings of those
and everything to this point the
following six uh recommendations from
this committee through to
council as as part of a submissions
process and it's no different
to let's use annual plans as an example
there is still a motion that is recorded
that recognizes that the submissions
received in the
processes recognized or
endorsed from my understanding that's
what this this Clause is uh Council SOA
thanks Mr chair I had raised my hand to
say that um in moving in seconding we
did need to um choose at number six and
number
nine so you'll dealt with six um nine um
I intended to move that we go for option
a noted yeah and I guess my query came
about because it uses the word council
not this
committee and generally obviously
committees from my knowledge we
recommend to council
and I just wonder how coun Council gets
involved in a recommendation that this
committee is doing well this is part of
council's process it's just it is we are
we are the committee we are not
Council but the process is councils
which is why the final recommendation is
to council with the decision is ratified
okay sorry I just couldn't understand
the okay the the language Council SOA
thanks I think that issue was partly
dealt with two and number eight we we're
we're recommending to council that we
choose to decline the
objections um and can I just add to
number
10 at the moment it says agreed to
ratify the revocation of the
land it needs to say the land Reserve
status and for that to be declared
Surplus just missing a few words so up
to land Reserve
status
and be declared Sur let the land be
declared
Surplus just if we recommending it to
council we want the wording to be
exactly right thanks
lley
Tom thanks chair so my question is
related to recommendation six um where
we're asked to determine whether we
should accept to reject um disallow
objections to the revocation um so my
question which is related to that chair
is as I understand it um
these uh small pieces of land um when
Reserve stus is revoked and I know that
two of them are not Reserve but all four
of them um comply need to comply with
the district plan
I don't know if it's a question for you
Caroline or a question for Jonathan so
I'm trying to understand what's what
actually could be done on them am I
right in thinking it's actually too
small to build a a house Jonathan it's
like three chair yes that's currently my
understanding they Zone rural so they
require to be a larger size right so
going on to
comment um I mean it seems to me when I
look at the four there are three that
are contiguous with the house and garden
next door um and therefore as suggested
you would think logically you know if
anybody's got used to them it probably
would be the next door um house and I
know it's recommended to suggesting that
some discussions are held with them hard
to see anybody else can make use of it
when I look at section one um it is an
orphan um and that it is not next door
to anything
basically so when I look at the um
submission by manena in respect to land
I I wonder whether we should give
particular consideration to their
proposal um when we think about section
one given that it is not next door to
any house and sits on its
own Caroline do you have a response to
that or no I appreciate the feedback
this um the process that we're going at
the moment is to do the revocation of
the reserve status so the next stage
would be where we would address the
issue that um councilor Campbell just
raised thank you I think section one is
not part of the reserve though it is the
it's fee simple h no it's not a reserve
no but you're rate your answer still
thank
you yeah um recommendation 12 can we
just
go so just with respect to the use of
the
fund
um what
so that's in compliance with what or is
that just the um Park saying this is
where we think it's best allocated that
that's what happens to reserve status
land yeah but have we had it that's the
same discussion we had around Donovan
Park yes so that that's a legal
requirement unless it's requested to be
different by the minister from it with
the
minister I'm not sure it depends on the
land status uh the underlying land
status as to whether the funds from a
sale go elsewhere so if the land was
derived for example from um from the
crown that money would be um the sale
would go through lens and the money
would not come to council this is not
the case
here yeah but and what I'm just trying
to understand is you know does this
create a precedent for us no it follows
precedent it follows so if there's a if
a different pieces of land come up and
we want to um challenge where those
funds go
to does this bind us in any way um this
decision if we I wouldn't say it binds
us this decision is following the
process that we must if you want to try
and break that bind with a with a future
block of land good luck deal with that
when it happens it's it's it wouldn't be
easy but I wouldn't say that it's not
insurmountable would you would need to
make um
a very good case but this is following
the process that is is laid out yeah in
place but there is an opportunity to
challenge where the funds end up through
the minister is that correct Michael do
you have any I couldn't com not with
this particular thing but I'm just
trying to understand I couldn't comment
that on that specifically um but as with
all things there's always an opportunity
to do something different but you would
generally need permission from it but I
would need to spend more time
actually looking at that and working
with Carolina and her team to understand
where that would go and how that would
look like and what the chance of that
happening would be and and to a degree
it would depend on the block of land and
status that it
holds so the higher the reserve status
the more difficult it would be to break
away from it
bring um right um two comments first one
under the heading of legal implications
it talks about encroachment of U some of
the neighboring properties onto these
particular Parcels of land and when you
look at the uh inago map it's got from
the
2022 uh aerial mapping it shows in
detail how um a couple of the sections
have spilled over and in fact one has uh
dwellings on it now when we obviously it
says there that encroachments have to be
um removed or whatever how do we know
about land contamination how do we know
that um someone hasn't you know parked
something there stored something there
when we come to sell it because
obviously we'd assume there is no
contamination but is it is it our job to
uh when we put it on the market to know
that it's contamination free or is it bu
aware that's my first question I have
another one after
that you'd like a bite at that one
there's a part of me that says it should
be buer whereare but it would depend on
the activity that's been taking place on
the property well that's what I mean how
do we find out yeah but but that said
there could have been activity taking
place on that property that wasn't
permitted um that's what I may be
hinting at the word encroachment sort of
says that it's no encroachment is
different that's physically moving on to
it but the contamination would come from
from an
activity um encroachment doesn't
necessarily imply
contamination okay um leave that one
then but if if you if somebody was
buying it we would assume they would go
and have a look at it and if there's
something if there's a whole lot of dead
cars lying on there you'd start to
wonder if there was a degree of
contamination that had come from them
completely yep the second one is Under
The Heading of climate change now again
with these aerial maps we have are
fantastic cuz we've got two we've got
one from 1951 and we've got one from
and it shows the rapid Retreat of the
sand
Junes um between those sections and the
ocean
um unfortunately under climate change it
really doesn't mention anything about
the potential Hazard area that this area
would be in um and if you only have to
look at that map that's 70 years worth
of movement and it's quite
noticeable so sandin by their very
nature and this is this is established
through resource management and in fact
a hearing I've dealt with move oh they
do but if you're a climate change
fanatic um you could argue the other way
no relevance under the RMA sorry but uh
I'm just saying there's no uh so there's
no concern about the sea level rise in
that area for us selling sections in an
area that may be hazardous for
that um I my answer to that would be be
covered under the district plan
understanding what the the regulations
are through there so again by but where
not not predominantly LLY I was just
going to comment the sand Junes in that
area have changed so many times over the
years that you could put almost any two
points in the history and have a
different scenario so it's been a rocky
Shore it's been sand Junes it's been a
rocky Shore again it's been part
sandunes part Rocky Shore it has changed
profoundly so that you've got the 50s
and the
2022 um you could have had the 7s and
2019 and you'll probably be got quite
different photographs for that area the
the changes have been profound because
of where it
is from a a coastal perspective under
sea level rise um it depends also on the
rain that surrounds it and the angle
that it's coming at so if it was flat
you would have to say there is potential
for sea level rise to to have an
effective however it's heavily sloping
but but then again look at Blue Cliffs
it depends on the the angle that the
Sea's coming and the level of erosion
that's okay no no I just had to ask
question so again by beware and and we
don't have to worry about that thank you
ever the
salesman any other questions or
points okay with those clarifications in
the um motion I'll put that all in
favor I I I against carried and noting
the abstention of p
and and you only moved one to six
C you have to do the rest you have to do
the
rest I thought we moved them all I not I
noted the first seven process and
the I up no my apologies move 8 to 12
I'm hugely confident in the motion but
I'm sure we move more but for process
yep same again put that all in favor I
against carried
thanks thank
you uh Civic Awards this follows on from
a process that we discussed at Council
earlier um ran and we've looked at how
we can progress things and there's a
series of of recommendations in
here um K again um I will probably take
the report as read and if there are any
questions
um please do let me know thanks
councelor cracket then R um thank you um
when we're undertaking something like
this and I know the the report asks us
to think whether or not we'd like to do
this annually or trally but um I would
have thought that there might have been
an indicative cost breakdown as to what
that event is running this is going to
cost us because you've got your
promotion of it you've got your man
hours you've got your higher fee for the
cic you've got your food cost you've got
your
trophies yeah like there's there's a
financial commitment to to accepting it
as well as um a question around the
basis so I was hoping to see some
financials in here so cost minimal it's
it's a it's a certificate not a trophy
um a certificate um absolutely the cost
indication was given in the previous
report that went to council um and then
Council delegated to this committee to
make the determination so it isn't a
massive amount it's um you're absolutely
correct counselor all of those costs
that you've indicated um would be would
need to be covered it's in the order of
around
5,000 so um it's probably not so much a
question of financials for whether you
want to go annually or Tri annually but
whether you feel that it will best
promote the awareness of the awards and
the benefits to the
community Ria then Trish then
Tom thank you um my question is when we
were going through um reinstating the
decision to bring the awards back again
there was that question annually trial
or um every 3 years and I thought we'd
sat in the middle and decided to go
trianal I um through your chair I went
and very carefully checked the
resolutions and that call was left to
this committee there wasn't a final
decision made by Council thank
you Trish um just the time frame R I'm
not sure can you pull that microphone in
please Trish thank you do you have
enough time to get this ready to promote
by the 14th of March
yes seems pretty quick Michelle is all
organized and ready to hit
go Tom sorry I don't think I can turn to
sent you a question as a comment I guess
but um I I don't think we should
underestimate the cost as the wrong word
but certainly the time commitment that's
involved in doing this sort of thing
properly um you know for the mayor um um
the deputy mayor but I'll be ducking at
that point for the mayor and for the
others I mean I think it's it is
actually a lot of work if you if you do
I mean my own view is every three years
I think we did actually talk I think
you're right R I think we did actually
talk about two years at some point but
every year it would just roll around
you'd never stop never agree it does
make it a little less special Grant
sorry yeah um I'm in support of this um
I I think it's great that we celebrate
you know people in our community that do
wonderful things um and we've got a he
of a lot of those people and so real
supportive of it probably am supportive
of the TR
TR annual um basis um and and I think
that may give some more money to the
award um but equally there's a bit of a
challenge in there in keeping up with
those people that do great things
between the awards so that we can make
sure we capture them so um but yeah very
supportive I think it's a thing we
should do in our community thanks gr I
think you'll find next year that you'll
realize that trames run pretty quickly
yeah and get
[Music]
faster um okay as the as the instigator
I mean I'm obviously very supportive of
it again I feel that trienal is is a
better way to go simply because of some
of the points that are raised the draw
on staff time and resource but also that
it elevates the manner of of the the
process so I'm prep to move the
recommendations with um recommendation
for being
trienal thank you any further
comments if not I put the motion all in
favor against carried there something to
do tomorrow Michelle do you want to now
nominate Mr chair in accordance with
number two uh the person from this
committee yep just and potentially how
we're going to res the man
person whether it's a member of maner
Representatives or whether it's we
invite Thea to nominate
somebody at the pleasure of council I
mean I'm willing to step forward if you
want or if somebody else is interested
in it uh I can't answer Mano I think we
have to ask them which they would prefer
I was going to say Mr chair you've had
um experience so perhaps you should be
the person um not quite but thank
the one time I could have participated I
had a
conflict oh my
gosh um but happy to have a slice at it
in this instance I guess I have an
understanding of of what some of the
criteria were in the past um do you have
a suggestion around what's best for
manaa are you happy for us to draw on
you or do we need to go back to which of
the
raka I think something like this I mean
it's probably easier to on
as yeah yeah
something
consultation Evelyn was pointing at you
you need to get your microphone um no I
wasn't pointing at her I was I was going
to say something similar I believe that
uh those are the sorts of issues that
we're expected to step up to address um
so I don't have a problem it's just I'm
not going to choose which one of us it
is because that's not
fair Mr we go pay for sciss rock or
something yeah to save you the effort
could I um nominate the chair of
community well-being committee to be the
counselor
representative either one of man reps to
be the man
rep um and I see that the committee
nominated Community representative with
the first parti to be delegated by the
cheer of the community wellbeing
k um that's going forth and finding some
Earth well person in the community you
as the che to for this first time to and
I would notify the committee before the
process day but yeah so I I guess from a
timing perspective if we have it open
for Mona or Representatives depending on
who it it fits with most or they might
be a conflict depending on who's
nominated and we'll deal with that at
time so I'll move the solution to B and
C being the che
and one of man and D left to the cheer
to advise second for
that Tom thank you sorry I put that all
in favor I against carried thank you for
your forance and
next and that brings us to the
activities
report any questions on specific areas
through the report councilors raise them
now or forever hold your face um I had a
question Trish sorry um it's on on page
four just not it's about publicity about
the basketball hoop um I haven't heard
of this before and I wonder whether we I
mean it's great thing to happen I just
wonder whether there needs to be some
the probably has something on
this maybe you're not the target market
Trish I don't believe that dar
um i' just like to see it um publicized
yep it's very
used that's good um but I guess there's
the opportunity for some publicity fors
around there as well Grant yeah it's
more just a comment it's on the
basketball HS I went down to Russell
Square there um a couple weekends ago
and just the community that was
participating in the basketball hoops
the cooking area and the um the pump
track that's there and it just
reinforced um yeah you know how
important these sorts of things are I
mean I was there for about an hour and
there was eight or 10 people playing
basketball the whole time so good um the
one thing that was missing was toilets
we're on to that Echo the the very clear
feedback we received it in the ho yeah
but I think this is a great partnership
you know with basketball New Zealand and
we should look to try and continue to
partner to put these sorts of facilities
in our community because they do bring
communities together so thanks what I
was really also excuse me I was meeting
was that we should acknowledge that
partnership and celebrate that you know
that we're working with them
yeah just to the toilets the point that
was raised at nooi far um the response
was always oh well those toilets not too
far away um in South City and they said
yeah but it's on the other side of the
road and these are children it's like
good point thank you yeah sorry somebody
at the leely sorry on a totally
different issue on page 74 of 81 I'm
just interested in the um comment about
the possibility of utilizing the
adjacent building to the Scottish Hall
are we seriously looking at that could
someone comment on
that who's our venues
[Laughter]
person thej building
is that the Old South and times paper
storage assuming it means the older
storage I was just I was just interested
to see if there I hadn't realized we
were
seriously looking at utilizing it um
well we own it don't we yeah we do I
understood we did own it yes we
do that's fine no I was just interested
to hear how far our thinking might have
gone on we'll come back with that thanks
L
thanks any other items under the
activities report anybody wishes to
raise Steve I just on Scottish hold just
want to acknowledge the work that um
Jimma had done with the youth Council
over the weekend I went to the umbrella
market and um it was great to see the
space being used by the youth Council
and I think it it was a bit of a
surprise because initially there was a a
b plan was postp perment to the
Sunday um at least it was on the Monday
18 the youth council is um but then the
quick transition of it to the Scottish
Hall um was really good particularly
considering the weather there was some
feedback about um some people parking in
the area and getting a a parking fine
but it's like well no one said there was
free packing but the comms around that
PIV were quite effective too in terms of
the shift of the Scottish Hall so well
just well down to the team thanks sorry
well patronized too you know mainly the
proba their family but there was quite a
lot of people there I think from a youth
Council perspective what was really
successful is that normally they finish
in in November but this time they
organized a summer committee because
they had this event and so there was a
small group of them a core of them that
were were working through and made it
happen I think it recognizes some
Sterling work because they're not event
organizers by any sense but they
certainly put together a great idea and
and gave due um acknowledgement to the
Nelson City youth Council who I think
came up with the idea something's work
working well why not why
not thank you any other items anybody
wishes to raise Evelyn I was um quite
intrigued by um the report from the
library portraits of tahay users and
thought that
um our staff's lateral thinking is
something that we should applaud because
I I took their point really well that
using real people that really use the
library to promote the use of the
library as opposed to um you know an
actor from somewhere or a stock photo as
they acknowledge um it's all those
things that
make the connections between people and
the and the activities that we do so I
really want to acknowledge that um that
that's really good work on their
behalf thank you
other
points recommendation as the report is
received I'm happy to move it seconded
Grant put that all in favor against
carried councilors that brings this uh
committee meeting to an end thank those
that have joined us on the live stream
do we create a separate live stream for
the infrastructure committee so for
those that have been following us on the
live stream this stream will end
there'll be another one for you to click
on for the infrastructure committee and
in a couple of minutes it's going to
take us turn I suggest that we have a
short break sh and it would actually we
start at 3 p.m. Roger that so we'll uh
I'll close the meeting and
infrastructure we'll start at 3 thank
you thank
you